more than half of u.s adults so i
believe was uh 52
so when they have like these uh you know
preachers who out there and they call
they call them prophets right and
they're and they're in the 50 million
dollar airplanes and whatnot
academics people in seminary school
they'll t they teach this also people of
course call the gospel books matthew
mark luke and john
well they call it matthew mark luke and
john because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them sam fred jerry and harry
dr marwan muhammad how are you my
brother it's always good to uh
connect with you how have you been how's
everything
we're here trying to uh uh do what we
can as far as uh
it's trying to try to do dawah and and
trying to show the people you know the
beauty of islam and
and uh and just trying to to to to
to this dispute some misconceptions
how are things from your endeavor
everything's good alhamdulillah this uh
it's very fascinating i mean
you brought up this uh this uh new
statistic that came out more than half
of u.s adults
so i believe was uh 52 they
believed that jesus was just a good
teacher that he wasn't god
and it's the same thing that islam is
saying that jesus never claimed to be
god wasn't god
not only was he a teacher but he was a
mighty messenger one of the five
greatest messengers that we have
noah abraham uh moses jesus and prophet
muhammad just being the last
and then it's not peace be upon him all
but then also they
talk about that 30 of evangelicals
believe that jesus isn't god that i mean
you can't
imagine that now flip that imagine dr
marwan if you just had like 50 percent
of muslims believe
don't believe that prophet muhammad saw
some is is a messenger of allah or that
allah is god or something like to the
likes you know
yeah because what's amazing is the fact
that this is conservative with the
tenant of christianity
and the same thing um i mean we're not
here we're not
you know stepping on anybody's still but
according to
men's enemy does not believe
that jesus is god then that absolutely
takes them out of the fold
of mainstream christianity because
that's that's what
you know that's one of the tentative
christian is to believe in
that jesus christ is the son of the son
of god or
he is god that that's so what you're
saying is i mean you're confirming that
look it's a tenet
of christian faith that to believe that
jesus
is not only god but he's part of a
triune nature
and it gets confusing as we go along
from there
and again like what you said something
really important we're not trying to
disparage
uh on the christian faith for our
fellow christian friends out there but i
mean this is just us now
sharing what we believe to be the truth
in a respectful
um honorable way but now
also you have the statistic coming in
siding with
what we have in islam that he's uh that
he's not god nor did he ever claim to be
god
and that's very very uh very powerful
now i mean
this is extremely extremely um
um stunning because like look and to
kind of show you put you in perspective
i'm gonna i'm gonna read to you what
what's like the head
priests have said about this dessert so
this is what he said he said the
statistic
and this was uh um mentioned by stephen
nichols
this is what he said he said statistics
like this from the state of theology so
we can give us a quick
a quite a shock but there are also shed
light on the concern of
that many american christians and
churches have expressed for decades
as as the culture around us increasingly
abandoned its moral compass
professing evangelical evangelicals are
sadly
drifting away from god's absolute
standards
in in scripture then this is and this is
what's reported by steven nichols and he
is the head
of this uh theology of subhanallah
this is absolutely amazing because the
thing is i mean
this is absolutely shocking to many
christians
you know first of all more than half
americans
they believe that jesus christ
peace be upon him he is not god okay
but to us muslims and i think and i
think i need your
also input in this this is not
considered to be a shock for us because
we already believe that jesus christ
he is he is he's a mighty prophet
but unfortunately i think what i find it
really
bothersome to me personally is that
people like sometimes below the fact
that
someone is a proper religious they would
say
just a prophet what's your what's your
take on this for that
uh this is uh just to push the point
home so people can understand because we
have
tenants also in the dean in islam and
islam simply meaning to submit your will
to the creator of the heavens and earth
and we believe obviously that as a
muslim jesus submitted his will to the
creator that heavens and earth
and at his time you would make that
declaration that there's nothing worthy
of worship except the one god the
creator
god almighty allah and at his time you
would say jesus is the messenger
so it's just like taking that out now
you know if you
if you say and that's it you stop you
don't say muhammad
rasulullah and you just cut that half
out it's void it's bottle it's just
you know or if you take the five pillars
you know which you have in islam and you
take one of them out that's it you just
destroyed
everything so this is what what we're
saying like what they're saying
this is a pillar this is i mean this is
their theology their whole thing but
what
but what what's what what's your
question you talked about
about the belittling you know because i
think a lot of times when you mention
prophet you you you um i don't know if
you've ever seen that uh
uh l.a preachers have you ever seen that
show la preachers
no i don't know right okay so when they
have like these uh
you know preachers who out there and
they call they call them prophets
right and they're and they're in the 50
million dollar airplanes and whatnot so
they have this this in their mind when
you say prophet it's some person on the
south side some guy in this church and
he's a prophet
you know so they're like no no you can't
but when we say messenger prophet we're
talking about these people ain't
prophets
we're talking about people who god
almighty sanctions as prophets
noah abraham uh isaac ishmael
david these are the real messengers that
got the prophets and messengers that god
almighty so i think we got to clear this
up because there's a lot of
you know misconceptions within that by
itself
the issue here is that people belittle
like
the mightiness and the honor of someone
choosing
an individual to be a prophet of god i
mean this
is this is absolutely i mean like it's
such an
honor like so these are considered to be
the best being that ever walked in the
surface earth
and so this is not something and like
even i mean
according to islam i think and and you
think maybe comment in this
i mean according to islam not not all
prophets are the same level like whereas
we because that we have
you know five prophets who are
considered people
right yes the greatest i mean you've got
you have uh i mentioned them earlier
when we started five of the greatest
that i mentioned we have noah
right uh you have uh uh moses
you have uh jesus abraham you have
these are muhammad being the last and
final so you have the these are the
greatest
i mean and and jesus i mean when we
mention this
uh the commonalities of him being the
messiah
of him um being somebody who has such a
great status just in islam i mean you
know if you just utter one
um you know you often hear this thing uh
by some
uh ignorantly who will say like oh
muslims uh they
are anti-christ and and i asked you know
i ask christians and i'm sure you do
you've asked also how can we be the
antichrist when we love
christ when we love jesus christ just
mean the messiah the messiah you know
christos
and then translated you know the
anointed one so he had such a high
status you know and this doesn't
diminish him or put him down in any
which way
and i remember having a guest uh owen uh
one a christian
his name is benjamin and i had him on
the program and we were talking and he
was like when he started to hear some of
these
things that we're talking about some of
these bullet points these points very
important points he was like man
why and he went from being a hater of
islam to actually forming a connection
with muslims and defending
actually i did this program you can
watch it and defending
muslims and he changed his views he said
man these guys when they say jesus they
say peace be upon him
you follow me uh they they respect his
mother they respect him to such a high
level
so in no way is this a derogatory is it
a put down
in no way shape or form at all but just
uh identifying him how he identified
himself because he never as you know
never claimed to be god or a little son
of god
but he humbled himself and he worshiped
god and he called people to worship god
clear
and we're just we're just repeating that
message that he repeated
simple so and that's
i think this is the absolute stunning
that i see in this and and with that
gradually and subhanallah and this is i
i find it even without dawah like i mean
i think we all admit as muslims that we
are
you know we're not doing our fullest
potential
when we do dawah and this is kind of
gradual like by itself like without
any sort of foreign intervention people
arrived at this fact that's for me this
is absolutely amazing subhanallah
and as you know as muslims we believe
that
god almighty have installed what we call
the natural instinct
in a human being which is what we call
the fitra you know
and and for someone to arrive at this
naturally without any foreign
intervention i find that this
is absolutely amazing and i want brother
eddie i wanted to
kind of share this i don't want to put
this in the screen
with everyone so people will be able to
kind of see what are we talking about
here
um so so this this is brother look at
this
so when they were asked jesus was a
great teacher but was not god look at
this
only 27 of the people
said yes but the rest of them you know
they were not sure
and they agree the fact that he was just
just a teacher i mean again he he was a
great teacher
but again when we talk about like and
this is a big part part of the fact that
quite a few things he talked people he
taught people how to worship god like
you have mentioned he taught people how
for instance to to uh to submit to the
will of god he taught people pure
monotheism
you know um i mean do you see how
amazing this this graph
is it is and we don't just stop there
because again we're
even closer to his true teachings and
message message
and his true title because here just
says people are saying he was just a
great teacher no he was a great teacher
but
i mean he was a messenger of allah right
so you could be a great teacher at
school at the university and then you
know it just
stops there no no no he had a message
for humanity
he was a messenger he did he did
miracles
he came with signs he called people to
worship one and only one god
he never claimed to be god and he
brought evidence
he did those miracles we all we attest
to that i mean it's clear
so uh you you can't just and we don't
just stop there we
we continue on but we don't transgress
the limits and now
equal him in any which way shape or form
to being the creator that happens in
earth
that's just where you fully stop you
don't go there because a human being
cannot be god
so i mean and and and to kind of i want
to put everyone in the same perspective
as far as
showing people that you need that at the
end of the day we're not really
inventing this you know we're doing
we're just showing people what people i
mean what what's what's what
the new news and this this is actually
this is the actual article
uh uh uh and so so everyone could take
it they could take a look at it
um so this is this this so this is more
than half of the us adults
third person evangelical village is in
guardians and so this is what they asked
they said
in this in this in this in this study
this is what they have done
you know is it for this study evangelion
because we're identified identified as
people who strongly agree with the
following four
so so to be an evangelical you have to
have four
what are these things the bible is the
highest authority is what i believe
again you know the minority of the
minority of the people i believed in
believed in this the bible is the
highest authority you know it's
important for me to personally encourage
uh uh encourage non-christians to trust
in jesus
that's again this is something also very
minor people have answered this question
right
or or they answered it with yes jesus
christ death
on the cross was what was the only
sacrifice okay
and those who trust in jesus alone to be
to receive the the uh their savior
receive from from from god or the
salvation from god
for subhanallah this is absolutely yeah
this is this is this is uh stunning for
many people and subhanallah yeah
i was you know i would say this is not
nothing
outside of the fold of islam because you
know as muslims we believe that
that that this is what he chose all his
messengers
to do
right yes absolutely yeah and and that's
uh out of his
mercy and love he sent them as
guiders guiding us to the truth i mean
this is something that and when we
started off when you look at we said
that this is uh
this was something that's part of the
tenet of the
faith of theirs today but uh you know as
well as i do uh dr muhammad
when you go back and you really go back
to the true teachings of jesus this
wasn't
a tenant during his time or during his
sahabas his companions time
there was no such thing as a trinity
there was no such thing as worshiping
the creation
or worshiping jesus these were not the
teachings of his companions or any of
that so if you are a true christian
a true follower of christ at that time
you would be doing what muslims do today
and that's the pure monotheism directing
all your worship
to god almighty alone the one god i mean
this is
so the further you get away from that
you know the more corruption
the more tainting editing edition
addition subtraction and altering the
true message of jesus and so when we
see this we see people because there's
nature and nurture
so the child if you leave left that
child alone he's gonna just grow up
naturally to worship god almighty alone
now you've got to teach him this man is
god
indoctrinate him and then he goes away
from that right
and and and by the way i mean this is
again we're not really
bringing anything out of our pockets i
mean this is i want to make sure
that our viewers understand this this
this fact
the fact i mean really i mean we're not
just saying oh
we're just referring the quran as our
only source of of guidance i mean things
as muslims
we believe in the gospels of jesus you
know and we believe that jesus
you know if we if we look at even the
current bible
with scrutiny we will be able to find
some
many verses that indicate the human
aspect of jesus christ peace corps and
i'm gonna
i would like to share a few and then i
want
also brother eddie to comment in this
look for instance when when
when when we read this in the old
testament in the book of numbers 23 19
god says god is not a human that he
should lie
nor not a human being that he should
change his mind
i mean so god is i mean explicitly
saying god is not a human because
seeing as this is for us as as we
believe as muslims that
you know you cannot be when it comes to
a
muslim belief we don't believe that the
two
human and that can be a human and divine
at the same time
could you comment a little bit on that
why why this is considered
to us uh no no uh brother eddie
that reminds me you quoted the uh the
numbers uh
verse you also have hosea 11 9 for i am
god
and not men it's very clear but i like
to back it up when i talk to our
christian friends
neighbors to let them know because we
can entertain these verses
and god almighty and like you said i
mean we believe in the original
torah what was given to musa moses
and it's original today we don't have in
its original we believe in the injil
allah
calls it that and it's original right we
don't have it today
so what was given to zaboor and it's
original we don't have it today so you
have bits and pieces here of the truth
but that's why god almighty
allah sent the quran this is tamper-free
tamper proof
in his pristine form anyone who puts it
to to the test will conclude that it's
from the creator of heavens and earth
but now the bible as we have it if you
go to any
judge and you're uh bringing the
evidence
as soon as that evidence now has been
tainted you followed me
you cannot go ahead because we don't
have bible scholars tell us
we don't have a copy of a copy of look
again not to disparage on anyone i know
this could be sensitive
or a shock for a lot of people but these
are just what academics people in
seminary school they'll t
they teach this also people of course
call the gospel books matthew mark luke
and john
well they call it matthew mark luke and
john because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them
sam fred jerry and harry i mean they're
they're written by people we don't know
who they were written by
they are anonymous you might not think
so because they have the title the
gospel according to matthew whoever put
that title on it was an editor
later the followers of jesus were
aramaic
speaking peasants from galilee lower
class men
who were not educated in fact
peter and john in acts chapter 4 verse
13 are literally said to be illiterate
they couldn't read and write of course
not they were fishermen they didn't go
to school
the vast majority of people in the
ancient world never learned to read
let alone write and their native
language was aramaic
these books are written in greek by
highly educated
rhetorically trained writers who are
skilled
in greek composition so we're just
relaying the truth
uh now you have we don't have like many
bible scholars one
aaron has stated and many others we
don't have a copy of a copy of a copy of
a copy of a copy
of any original okay text right no
original about you don't have that
so imagine i make an analogy imagine the
police officer
dr marwan pulls you over and asks for
your driver's license
and now you give him a piece of paper
and he says what is this he says that's
a copy of a copy of my driver's
uh license no it's actually i lost the
driver's license where is it but it was
a copy of copy something that wasn't
even the original copy of that
i did i confuse you enough or do you get
the point and over there it has your um
date of birth it's changed then you have
your height
color of hair that's been edited and
it's like what is it will they accept
that
can you use that as a proof in a court
of law
you cannot do that so okay so that's
full stop the authenticity of the book
that would just in the court of law
today anyway it'll be thrown out but now
if we entertain like what you're saying
i mean you do have some verses you know
that that are clear
you know then you have like for instance
uh
jesus being saying that the father is
greater than i this is in john 14 28
right but then the teachings today is
that jesus is equal to the father so
here he's saying look that
god almighty is greater he's greater
than i greater than all
but then the teachings that you've been
that's the that's the the the uh
the nurture now now you're just feeding
this you know the indoctrination right
changing the text and the teachings
then you have another uh the lord where
he said peace be upon him in mark 12 29
the lord our god is one look look and
then
and then verses what the it's it's clear
and this is what islam is it's clear
he's one but then
verses now versus what's being taught
okay made up
that god exists as three persons you get
it and then we can go we can keep giving
examples i'll give you a couple more
real quickly
i by myself he's quoted as saying in
john 5 30
that i or myself can do nothing look you
go to the i just give an example you go
to the secretary says i can't do nothing
for you man i got to get approval from
the boss right
so jesus peace be upon him uh he's
telling you i can't do nothing
but then the teaching is that jesus is
is all-powerful
right uh one more in john 2017
it's uh stated that he's saying i
ascended to my father and your father
right this is my favorite verse by the
way
is it this is absolutely my favorite
verse because this one
he's expected to say i'm gonna go to my
father
and your father my god and your god
yes subhanallah to my god and your god
my father and then the teaching is that
he's the only son of god so you see we
made a difference a contrast okay this
is what he's saying explicitly
clear it's just you don't need a you
know a phd a doctorate degree
clear versus but then what you have you
have people will throw in ambiguous and
you you you hear this all ambiguous
verses
you know i and the father are one
whoever sees him you know all these uh
uh ambiguous that can have multiple
meanings it's not clear so when you put
the clear
next ambiguous then you'll see and you
compare that contrast that
with for all them other messengers
brought and the quran then and if you're
sincerely looking for the truth
allah god almighty will guide you to to
the truth which is
clear exactly what i found really
interesting the good thing is
the muslims have this right when when it
comes to
the akita or or or or trying to
prioritize the tennis
if you ask any scholar of islam
he would tell you that she would build
ambiguous
verses on clear
clear verses like and that's why and
allah even mentioned this
is that there are some verses so there
are some verses in the quran that are
clear
and sometimes they're you know they're
mutual
like they're they're like other verses
you know so what we do best
part of our you know and part of our
the core part of our religion as muslims
that we take what is clear
and we build on it it's not the other
way around
like we can't build we cannot build
you know it translates clear facts
based on ambiguous verses you know
so and i think this is the part that
unfortunately we see many many
evangelicals are
you know when we when we try to to just
discuss with them
that they have it kind of upside down
because they say well they
wanted to translate what is ambiguous
but what is
what is clear based on what's in the big
ones but it should be the other way
around
and and this doesn't again it's common
sense and i just always repeat i mean
this is with
the utmost respect for all of our
christian friends and neighbors but you
just have to like
you know just use the same common sense
you use in a business deal
for math for accounting god almighty
allah gave us this common sense of
reasoning
use the same thing i mean because the
belief that jesus here as it's evolved
which we already stated it wasn't the
core
true teachings of any of the prophets
and messengers they brought
this goes opposite to it but the belief
nowadays that's evolved
there's a whole history behind it you
know how it did why it did that jesus is
god part of a trinity
the incarnation of god on earth versus
if you just look common sense again just
look
that jesus peace be upon him he was born
he ate food
right and god almighty allah he mentions
this in the quran don't you see how they
look how they ate food
because what goes after that then you're
going to go use the restroom you're
going to use the bathroom how can you
equate that that attribute uh that
defect
now of caring feces because just let's
be blunt about it a human being carries
feces from day to night right even he
went from the diaper
you know now inside it's it's covered
but your your care
carrier feces how are you gonna that's
the insult to the creator of heavens and
earth
he slept he prayed and the list goes on
he had limited knowledge
all those are the attributes they're not
befitting god right we say glory
subhanallah
glory be to my lord the most high he's
the one with the perfect names and
attributes
when you make him a human being now he
has deficiencies you have insulted him i
give this example if you wanted mercy
and you went to a judge imagine you're
you know at the at the mercy of a judge
and you call him a son of a monkey right
say hey mr judge you know and you
insulted
you said you know hey you son of a
monkey right can you save me get me out
of here
i mean but now imagine look and there's
a verse in the bible
uh that talks about what is man but a
worm you know and the son of man look
you know this verse that i'm talking
about yeah yeah
yeah i read it but i can't recall so now
you you when you bring
god almighty you know who's the most
high and you put him on earth
and you have him eating sleeping and and
defecating and you wouldn't want to be
called
a son of a monkey but what are you
insulting god people don't think
common sense we got to use our common
sense and think with all due respect
yeah i mean i think i think the beauty
in islam
and and what's understanding by the way
and many other like even
in judaism they have the same thing that
that we have
when it comes to like the distinction
between the divine being and the human
being
is that you you put each and every
individual
on his status like what is this we would
call an ant and ant
and we would call human being a human
being we would call it an uh
what's what what's what you know so we
put each one of them
so in the same token i wanted to
emphasize this just because we're not
calling jesus god that does not mean
we'll be literally
no god is god a prophet is a prophet
and regular human beings a human being
that's it you know
yeah yeah it's kind of like what looks
when when we read and i this is one of
my favorite verses
in the bible it says this is what jesus
said my teaching is not
my own it comes from the one who sent me
and this is this is in john 7 16 to 18.
it it comes from the person who sent me
anyone who chooses to do
the will of god will find whatever my
teaching come from god or whatever i
speak of my own
he is blatantly saying that
look whatever whatever whatever i'm
saying
is not from me god has sent me
you know you know god is he's the one
who's
all the good teaching is coming from
allah i i find it
extremely amazing when we read these
beautiful verses
because as a muslims and i think many
people agree with me that
you know we don't believe that that all
of the bible is corrupted
some some of it is it has on the truth
but yet as you mentioned before some of
it
it have changed over time yeah i mean
obviously you could find i mean some
amazing teachings
uh in the bible they'll you know teach
you to be a good righteous upright human
being
so many similarities you know between
islam
and uh the teachings and when people
look at it but then you have additions
you have things that have been added uh
that verse i was talking about earlier
was job 25
6 you know how much less immortal who is
a maggot this is in the bible and a
human being who is
who's a worm you know just illustrating
you know when
you cannot god almighty is perfect he's
perfect there's no defect
nothing but you cannot now take a in
perfect human being and now try to make
him into a god
it doesn't make sense and this was
something that
wasn't taught by when you go back in the
chronological order when you look at the
message of abraham
who god almighty allah tells us he
wasn't a jew or a christian
right he wasn't a jew or christian but
he was a pure monotheist
right and he called his people to
worship did he call his people to
worship jesus
no he called him to worship the one god
the creator that jesus worshiped
so that's the fitrah not right now if
they're listening people are listening
this just you don't have to now now if
you do kufri you cover it up and you're
rebelling and you're fighting but
this doesn't take a lot just takes
common sense
to be like wow that actually makes sense
right and if you let that in and you
just you know you're sincerely seeking
the truth god almighty is gonna
gonna guide you and then if you have any
questions uh you can come to our brother
dr
muhammad marwan ask a muslim right don't
go to the
the haters go and connect and ask a
muslim this is the way you know what i
mean
so the thing is i want to really uh if
you could kind of
elaborate a little bit effie and on some
of the things they said
like we said that god almighty has
certain descriptions for instance when
we say
even when you look at this word the word
god in in the website dictionary there
are certain
descriptions that be fitting that like
for instance we say god is all-knowing
god is all living god is all-powerful
god is not he's self-sustaining you know
so when we so so this is by definition
and
and in islam we cannot say
uh um two things can co-exist together
meaning that
we say that a human being cannot be
divine and a human being
because you cannot have a squirrel a
square and a circle in the same hand
yet in the same token we see for
instance some verses
in the bible that support the fact that
jesus
even he's he's saying that i'm a human
being like for instance i think you
mentioned
one of it indirectly he said that he
uses biscuits on him in the end
of the bible he said that i don't know
when is the hour right
yeah yeah this this is showing that his
lim
you know you often ask you say was he if
you quote this verse i mean he's either
uh you know and again this is all due
respect was he just ignorant ignorant
means he didn't know or is he lying when
he's asked this verse
so you know god can't be ignorant and
god doesn't lie so when he's asked this
what is it he just didn't know so equals
he's not god
simple even i mean so so the christians
would not feel
like we're uh um um trying to
put him down i mean like even when he
was
asked about an hour he said i don't know
i mean so and many human beings and any
prophet of god when he was asked about
the hour
he would not because this is something
of the knowledge of the unseen
the knowledge of the divine god almighty
yeah but but think about that that's
when he's being asked when is that day
or hour
he's saying nobody knows the same and
now you link that like you just uh
beautifully said prophet muhammad was
asked the same thing right he said what
have you prepared for it huh
he didn't know that's that that not even
the angels no but god almighty knows so
that goes back to what we're saying
perfect names and attributes right god
is all-knowing he knows everything
you still gotta call a plumber you still
gotta call electrician because
you might be good at framing putting up
drywall but your resources you're a
doctor actually by profession right
but do you know all the skills in all
the areas they're specialists in certain
areas
you're limited right for a foot doctor
you call it podiatrists is right
so we're limited yeah so god almighty is
not limited his knowledge is
all-encompassing
perfect but jesus peace be upon him and
this is just common sense he didn't know
everything this is no disrespect to him
or our christian friends and neighbors
but many who are i've interviewed over
the years you know many who have uh
theologians and people who have just
like been truthful with themselves
who really like you know turned the
light bulb on and they were like hold on
they looked at the text and they saw
that they're preaching one thing
dr gerald dirk was one of them he was he
went to seminary finished divinity
school harvard
uh divinity school and then he was
looking at the text and he saw this is
not in the bible we're preaching it
he was trying to be real with himself
and then he looked into islam and
exposure to it and he accepted it right
so it's not like we're trying to tear
everything down you just got to continue
on
there's another messenger who came and
that's prophet muhammad peace be upon
him that's what
we believe islam is nothing but a
continuation of the
of the the message of jesus christ peace
be upon him and anything is upon allah
but i think people are not
exposing or not showing the fact that i
think and i think
you mentioned this on earlier on that
the original
followers of jesus christ basically upon
them were not i mean they did not
believe in the trinity they did not
believe jesus
i mean and i and i really and the thing
is like don't take our words for it
i really encourage anyone who's looking
for the truth to look to
search this search and i and i really
want to encourage everyone to do this
search the people who are named the igbo
knights please i mean i would i would
ask you please go to google now and
search
who are the ebonites they're the
original followers
of jesus christ people know what what
does what did the ibus believe in they
believed that
jesus christ was what a human being he
was a prophet of god
uh the the the the the measure teens and
this is kind of a
an evolution of this state they believe
the same thing jesus
[Music]
was was
[Music]
was not god and even when it comes to
like for instance the
the the council of nicaea who did the
which is the very first convention that
that was brought up
brought together to see to to figure out
the nature of jesus
you know was everybody agreed the fact
that jesus christ was was god
no i mean there was you have you have
the aryans
which is an important he was him
and with his crew came into this council
to say that jesus christ was not god
you know so hanallah this is nothing new
and i mean i mean just to kind of
support the point we still have
christians nowadays and even though
people don't don't consider them
christians who believe jesus was not god
like
we would call them what um unitarians
right yes that that that's a great
example and i i can give you
another example of those because this
connects
because sometimes as a christian you
might be thinking like hold on
am i like uh doing the wrong thing here
uh my my fit up my nature is pulling me
to what you guys are saying right
uh but then you just give me some
examples when you go back and back and
back and you see like the original way
was that pure monotheism right the true
christians the followers of christ they
didn't believe in the trinity
they believed that jesus was a messenger
and then even in the heart of europe
where my family is from bosnia they had
at that time they abandoned they went
away from the church
uh some call them the booger meals those
close to god
uh some call them the unitarian
christians but history shows that
they were some of the largest the
largest group of
christians that except so they were they
were those who called themselves
christians
they didn't worship jesus they believed
he was a messenger they didn't pray in
the church they prayed outside
and then what happened was when islam
came to them it fit like a glove
and then they ended up 60 they say 60
000 plus
accepted islam and and to this day
that's where you have in the heart of
europe and the balkans in bosnia and
then spread from there
you have those christians unitarians who
actually accepted islam and remember
islam is just the the encapsulation of
the
the meaning of submitting your will to
the will of the creator that heavens and
earth and this is how you acquire peace
and get the paradise in the next life
and avoid the hellfire
that's salvation that's your salvation
[Music]
and and again this is something that
again unfortunately
you know not a whole lot of people know
about this and the part of
our goal is to kind of show the people
that their real history again this is
nothing like really we invented this
like or
this is like if you look up any history
book you know they would tell you
this this is there you know and at one
point uh
to kind of share again not a lot of
people know about this at one point
the majority of europe was
unitarian yeah yeah yeah the majority of
europe
at one point after after the death of
constantine
uh they were even they believed in the
the belief of
what the ibo ebonites had in which that
you know
jesus christ please be upon him was not
that again and with all of this this is
this is very very important survey that
i think that it's really
an eye opener for many many many people
i mean at the end of the day
we ask we ask people to kind of you know
look explore but just like we tend to
make
we investigate over uh over lively
worldly matters just like we tend to
investigate to look to look at the truth
of anything that exists in this world we
investigate
to know what is the best medicine we
investigate to know who is the criminal
we investigate
to know to to to know what is the best
what is the best
food to eat at we investigate all sort
of things but i think it's really really
worthwhile and it's really really
important
that we investigate why god have put us
in us
to investigate and what's the real
nature
of jesus to investigate that all is
these religions were brought
for the or what that god have intended
for us to have
one and only religion for us to one one
path because
you know yes we as muslims were
obligated to respect everybody
you know that's this is a no-brainer but
in the same token
it does not make sense that god has
shown made all these religions
right toward him uh because they cannot
be all right
there was always one way from the
beginning you had one humanity and one
way of life
that was sent for humanity and that
started with the first man adam and he
was told to do nothing else but to
submit his will to the creator of the
heavens earth equals islam he was a
muslim
muslim is one who submits his will to
the will of god and throughout time god
almighty allah sent messengers
and not different religions because we
cannot have it's not all roads lead to
rome no because
what's going to happen one one messenger
is teaching that what
uh one thing another one contradicting
that message no it's the same message
submit your will not to creation or to a
human being
or to angels or saints or messengers but
to submit your will to the god
of the uh of jesus of creation allah
in aramaic allah in hebrew allah the one
god
and do good deeds that's the
manifestation of your faith you know to
be upright to be honest to be
honoring your mother and your father to
be a good human being according to god's
will not your
will not your desires and that's always
been it's a chain of revelation that's
been there
since the beginning and i think that
like you so beautifully said if people
investigate more
not just fitting in you know on sundays
or even a lot of muslims we have to call
that out a lot of muslims just by muslim
by name tag
you follow me they just be oh because
they have their faith we have our
but they don't know the tenants they're
not praying they also you have to like
consciously submit your will and islam
is evidence-based right
it makes sense it's there for the for
the blind man who could see who can't
see
everything is light clear clear as day
but you got to be sincere with yourself
and you got to do like you said research
and
really want to know why you're on this
earth you know you're going to leave
sooner or
am i living for l am i going when i die
and the quran
has everything that our human being
needs to be successful the quran and the
sunnah in this life and the next it's
there it's straightforward
and we just got to like you know open
our hearts and minds and ask that's i
always leave people with the homework
if you want to know the truth ask the
owner to the creator of the heavens and
earth
do your homework say guide me guide me
guide me and for the christians
look at the lord's prayer what do you i
often think look at that
it's like the el fatiha isn't it oh our
lord who art in heaven hallowed be thy
name thy kingdom come
thy will be done that's islam thy will
be done that's islam right there
and there's no praising of anyone other
than the creator of the heavens and
earth in that prayer right
that's true yeah i mean again i mean
this is this again this is this is this
is the word of jesus
i mean this is this is what he did in
israel this is where he called on oh
this is
who who he prayed to when he when he
when when he was in and and
the god of the seminary again and again
my desperation
i am really honored i'm really honored
to have brother eddie inshallah
you know this is going to be the start
we want him to have maybe we could do
this in
both the ends me coming to him and him
coming to us
there's a lot of things that we need to
talk about again and he
we need to talk more about you know the
salvation through islam
we want to talk about either why is it
important to have
you know to worship only one god what's
his monotheism
you know and how to avoid chip there's a
lot of things that we need to talk about
but yeah with this being said and i
think we we covered the subject
and exactly we are yeah i mean allah
bless you and reward you
for having him and he's a he's a very
very busy man
and he is he's uh you know he's and i
encourage everyone
to to to go into his uh facebook page
and
and to the radio show face and like it
and follow it
mashallah they have very very important
things uh to share with us
uh may allah brother thank you allah
reward you inshallah
um we would end with this and again
i encourage everyone if you have any
questions if you have any doubts please
let us know
you could you could watch the dean's
show you
[Music]
and if you like this episode of the show
like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now